[Music]
guys I have a confession to make on a
Florida Gator bar it's hard a floor gang
hurt mental then why my butt feels so
good what's up everyone I'm back on my
old set up social distancing is at the
edge of the seat literally quick
question is it for gang if the chair
touches the floor yeah yeah we're still
yeah I dip I still feel it oh I'll be
back on the floor before you know it
don't you worry but now we're doing it
my assumption about me video I've been
seeing these on trending so let's hope
this one gets on trending guys come on
smash like can we get it what do you
guys assume about me I asked my members
become member subscribe join member epic
join member army nation
but before we begin quick word from our
sponsor party I've been playing a lot of
rocket League lately and in game
matchmaking can sometimes be amazing and
sometimes be their worst experience ever
this guy's said I'll tell you what I'll
lose your mom's effing fanny what a
great teammate I love to play more with
him so I know all about ending up with
the wrong kind of players but the fact
is there's a ton of great players out
there and especially in rocket League as
well sometimes I end up with people that
are so nice that it makes me regain
respect for Humanity so why not just
play with good players every time well
there's a new app for that cold party
that way in any game not just rocket
League you get the perfect squad you get
to play games and you unlock
achievements together even better you
can actually make money from hosting
parties and helping gamers that's
activate now that's a gamer right there
highly recommend check out party
Lincoln's in new description and use the
code pewdiepie to sign up anyone can
sign up to party and earn money it's not
about how good you are as a gamer
Armellini followers you have it's about
contributing positive to the gaming
community and I think it's a great
service that I'm so happy to I'm able to
support check it out
link is in description and I'll see you
guys in game make some friends in online
why not
it's cool ok now back to assumptions ok
number one you can't go outside because
you'll get stopped everywhere
that's not true I don't get stop that
off there I think it's that every time I
go outside I have to be conscious that
it's gonna happen I think that's more
that's annoying then the fact that it
does usually I like it it's just it
changes your perspective on going
outside which I don't always like okay
heard this crazy one where they said
PewDiePie does have no next what is this
garbage come on people think you are
uninformed about the world beyond Kings
and memes I mean yeah you're not wrong I
think the world I don't know much about
the world but I do have a good
understanding of myself which is my
world which is all that matters
thank you you seem well educated humble
and and I thought I read genius first
yes and generous your wealth has an
inflated your ego and you seem to be
passionate about what you do look at
Timmy you're supposed to be going on
leaves not to be so nice Jesus I don't
know where I go on this now money hasn't
inflate my ego because I don't value it
that much anyway I think when people put
more importance on money than it is
that's when that sort of thing happened
educated no I don't really think so
humble yeah maybe generous and that
could be more I could be more generous
let's get real here you really hate
compliments yes but they're meaningful
to you I don't know if meaningful that's
right word I do appreciate it of course
who doesn't like compliments but they do
generally make me feel uncomfortable
most of the time and I think I also am
aware that I like to compliment people
because I want them to feel good I mean
maybe it doesn't come across as hundred
percent genuine even though I wanted to
so I feel like in the back of my mind
when I receive money I'm projecting my
own way of approaching compliments unto
other people ah you're really smart and
an intellectual yeah actually kin pal I
feel like I'm very dumb I'm not gonna I
feel like I'm dumb smart if I really put
my mind I'm more of a slow thinker I
would say and I think that's why I like
philosophy I'm not so snappy as I'd like
to be but thank you I always thought you
were a genuine guy but often we'd go
through an existential crisis when
things go wrong no not when things go
wrong just my well
being and how how things seem online are
not the same thing I would say but not
anymore no more existential crises yeah
I wanted to do something like dab
ironically but I feel like even that
doesn't count as ironic anymore but I'll
do it anyway who cares it's 20/20
anything can happen I think some people
think you are overrated because you're
just at home recording videos but they
don't understand the immense work you
went through and stuff I think hmm I
don't know about that it's not like its
immense work I'm gonna use that
adjective but if anything I think people
under assumed or evaluate the risk I
took going into YouTube during that time
when it wasn't even a job at all it's
something that I wanted to pursue so the
risk involved with approaching it and
the consistency required to perform and
constantly change and adapt in the
platform to keep things fresh which is
ironic flora gag oh I think it's my
point is it's easier to just look at one
of my latest videos and be like I don't
really get it this is not that big of a
deal and I agree yes
but there's this whole catalogue of
years and years alright it takes time
all right
obvious one is that you're right leeming
I hear that a lot whenever I watch your
videos what from me not from me who is
telling you from watching my videos I
don't know where my political views are
and I don't care to state them online
anyway because it doesn't matter that's
not why I make videos do you feel that
when you were in office in the office
I'm like another political goddammit
so I used to have an office a few years
ago and they assumed that I had a battle
and State at the time it seemed like as
a youtuber it was like okay we're gonna
build like a team and we're gonna have
like an office and we're gonna like make
this a production and all of a blah and
I'm like yeah I guess that makes sense
from a natural progression standpoint
but from what I like about YouTube no I
and I think it's the same with you guys
that's the charm of YouTube aside it's
not necessarily these big productions
big words helped me at least that's what
I enjoy I can enjoy production stuff as
well I think the multitude of YouTube is
what makes it fun
there's no right and wrong but is this
going from what I prefer that's what I
learned bad mental state always it's
like I did a video celebrating my 10
years and I'm like oh that was a tough
year oh my god that wasn't even tougher
year oh my god it's like I I think for
the first time in a long time I'm right
I'm really glad to be making videos and
just doing my thing and not dealing with
all this drama for once everyone thinks
you're really humble but you've actually
had to think about and deal with your
fame and money through a philosophical
approach and you'd had ups and downs
with the ups and downs absolutely I
think my interesting philosophy doesn't
necessarily have anything to do with my
situation on YouTube it's just something
I enjoy and I like to draw parallels
between it from my own experiences but
it's not something that I did because to
deal with fame and money know on how to
deal with it I'd like to think you act
just as crazy off-camera and that might
send was some time like to stab you in
the back because she can't have - no
that's not true I think myself is says
I'm way too serious off-camera
which I don't like but I don't like when
people are always crazy I think a lot of
youtubers that our act crazy are
actually crazy but I I'm not the case
and I think that's why I like about my
personality is that I can have different
sides of the same personality I think
that it's more interesting
you're a proper introvert that would be
a really good friend once you are close
enough to someone well I like to think I
am but I don't have that many close
friends I would say I'm in ambivert both
introvert necks extroverted but probably
more introvert I assume you don't have a
skincare routine hey I do
I'm oyster right my skin gets very dry
thank you very much
I tried skincare at teens and I can't
tell a difference I'm like I feel like
this is just expensive you're self aware
of your attractive qualities
narcissistically mm-hmm well I do know
what I like about myself but I know if I
wanted to look the best I had to look I
wouldn't be rocking this haircut and
this beard okay I'm well aware of that
so I wouldn't say I'm that narcissistic
about my attractive qualities the floor
gang is a cult no it's a religion come
on that I hate the spotlight
whatever let's make this fake I'm just
thinking I guess I don't like speaking
unless I feel very confident that I have
something to contribute so if I'm put in
the spotlight on deliberately I don't
thrive on the attention that that
generates that I think a lot of people
get energy from that doesn't mean
there's a right and wrong it's just how
I am
at big that you were actually Felix
check know that guy Hayden we need to
cancel Felix Kjellberg he always gets
away with it it's always PewDiePie does
this PewDiePie to say no one talks about
Felix Kjellberg huh people are seeing
assume you're still the old PewDiePie
and haven't changed for the better after
your controversies yeah it's been pretty
clear that the people that have made up
their mind about me are just gonna think
that way forever and I'm okay with that
that's their problem not mine your
choice of clothing is an expensive and
unrealistic for some people check out
the merch guys buy it yes I think you're
right I try to avoid fast fashion
because it's not good for the
environment but it's not something that
I judge out there for if they don't or
wear expensive clothing to sort of
boasts about status or something I just
think it's better okay it's better
better quality better design it lasts
longer better for environment more
ethically produced since I have the
choice to do it then why shouldn't I
people think you play horror games as
your main content yeah it's funny this
happens all the time especially when I
get recognized that's how I know I don't
need that whole what it would we had a
code word before if you were gonna meet
me on the street what would say if math
related to science I don't need it I can
tell ya I mean I yeah I do are you just
want to be polite and reply as well it's
so it's so weird some people I know
think that you're petrified wouldn't
thinking about letting go of YouTube
like you don't know what next
I think the break that I had this
January was a very good
in Decatur because I wasn't sure as well
but I definitely learned that I'm I
don't have to make it to videos I was
really happy not doing it as well but
it's just something I enjoy I'm not
afraid of letting go
that doesn't mean I'm gonna stop I'm not
I'm not planning on it okay calm down if
anything I enjoy YouTube now like these
past months has been the most fun I had
in a long time especially building
members that's been really fun you're
shy but won't admit it
yeah I'm shy what do you want huh thank
you god damn Mike I hate to setup no I'm
shy but I don't like it that that's the
truth I try to push myself to not be but
it's really hard and it comes to them
people kick when it stays and it comes
across very obvious when they interact
with other people online sometimes and I
hate it and that makes it worse the fact
that I'm aware of it it's like oh god I
got a hiccup sign if he doesn't need the
money why is it so worried about
monetizing his videos clearly you just
care about money that's an assumption
people make I'm not gonna stand in line
and say I don't like money
of course if I have to the choice of
having money and not having it I will
choose to rather have it thank you very
much
however it's not a driving factor for me
it's not what makes me want to make more
videos
it does help and having YouTube as a job
has helped me be more consistent with it
so it has some factor I would say but
for example with memberships all the
money goes to charity and I really
really like kind of starting from
scratch and building a community again
from the bottom and that's it's been
really motivating and fun for me and I
don't make money out of the members
anyway so I think it's clear where to me
at least where my motivation is that it
doesn't make it less motivating for me
highly self-aware I'd say yeah I think
you took kind of forces you to become
more self-aware it forces you to be
self-aware especially when you're on
there's a lot of scrutiny because you
have to just be honest with yourself a
lot of times when people online get
upset about things you really have to
examine it sounds like I'm excusing my
past behaviour it's not what I meant but
when so many people hate you online you
just have to understand what is actual
ate and what is actual criticism and
do actually really take in a lot of
criticism but because I'm forced to
learn how to be self-aware I have to
I've learned to make the distinction of
okay what is actual criticism and what
is actual just random hate and I think
that's how I become more self-aware it
feels a bit cringy to say oh I'm so self
self-aware which me recognizing that is
kind of self-aware this guy's famous
just because he's handsome this guy is
number two and under most handsome faces
just because he's famous oh you walked
in your own trap a loophole
just like when I drink while peeing good
comment very nice I have nothing to sex
you really dislike most of YouTube which
is why you don't collab with anyone new
it's not true a collab with ninja I
could live with James Charles and that
was fun and I'm not necessarily the
biggest fan but I still enjoy it I think
it's more the fact that I don't like
asking people hey you want to collab
that feels weird to me I don't know why
I really hate asking people for stuff
probably because people ask me
for stuff all the time for that I'm just
kidding
I do enjoy it that's what I'm saying I
just don't like asking my assumption you
enjoy interacting with fans even if you
can't do it often yeah absolutely
absolutely
I hold the meeting Greeks and everyday
stuff are always super fun Adam see how
I know one can just like that you're
uninterested in life now no I think for
the first time in a long time I feel
very enthusiastic about the future my
life and where things are gonna go next
so I'm happy I've seen a few people
assume you're bisexual what you said a
few times in lives and stuff but a lot
of time I honestly can't tell every
joking or not because you do use a lot
of sarcasm all right well let me clear
this up I'm not bisexual how where do
people make that assumption I find men
to be very gross and I don't even
understand how women can like men but
each to their own I guess you have a
habit like you are being recorded all
the time for example and you like
talking with yourself while playing
games even though you're not recording
know what the hell I know how to switch
it on and up it's very easy for me I
you script a lot of videos in my head
though if they're supposed to be
scripted I most of them aren't but if
there's a bigger video I usually don't
have to write notes before I'd Sisley
boom I have it in my head I always
assumed you were super short yeah and
guess what I'm 9 usually people that
seem you're tall because they don't see
you on camera what the hell all right
there you go there you go everyone
confirm I'm 180 by the way stop assuming
otherwise why is it even a thing even
though I say it 179 okay fine I think
you sometimes actually die no no no you
do like drugs like weed and stuff no god
I keep getting hiccups sorry I just had
lunch it's not me lying
I don't hiccup when I look didn't have a
whiskey face though you like Ben Shapiro
Paul Joseph Watson ed Trump although we
all know you clearly don't yeah it seems
like a lot of people wants to impose
political views onto me especially
better up here because he was on meme
review personally I don't like their
whole oh you can't interact with someone
just cuz you engaged with someone means
to share their political opinions which
isn't true and I hate that idea that you
can't even talk to each other what's the
point I just find that very toxic how do
you change people's mind if you don't
engage with each other that's not why I
did the collab a for anything I did it
just because I thought it was really
funny that's the sole reason and I feel
like that's a good explanation of all my
controversies because I've always just
proved okay this is funny to me
some people might misunderstand this but
it's really funny that's what's putting
me in trouble for most things you are
action NOLA no 179 I'm alright I'll
measure myself like at some point
subscribe and come member join the
member gang and then we'll settle it
once and for all
alright you still want to literally your
channel and start over again because you
like warm since their communities
well not anymore now that we can build
members I keep chilling for members but
it's been so fun I really really really
enjoy that that's really was reminding
me of what I enjoy by YouTube it's not
like I have to be forced or surrounded
by obviously super fans but
who doesn't like to be around positive
people I don't know I do I mean I don't
I do I do
a lot of people have the assumption that
you don't work much is that true I would
say I have worked a lot yeah I work a
lot I work a lot
- ever definitely say it - I guess I
compare myself to other jobs and I know
there's so many harder jobs out there
especially with with how much you work
so it feels a bit mean to say I work a
lot but at the same time I feel like I
figured out how to be very effective
with YouTube and that saves me a lot of
time and sometimes I can be frustrating
too because I making videos is what I
really enjoy and a lot of times like 90
percent of the work I do doesn't show
because it's not in videos and you know
like I said sometimes that can be
frustrating because it's like on talking
to all these different people about all
these different things that doesn't feel
like this is not what I signed up for
but it's necessary for me to maintain my
business I guess you know what I mean
you know what I mean that's why I like
live streams it's more time to engage
with you guys so become a more Vicki
description you had a STONER face whisky
face whisky face for sure
now you're annoying dude who do question
of things for views and fame I've
actually seen a lot of people assume
this like I some have deliberately got
into all these controversies which to me
so silly I know some people do obviously
create controversies deliberately but
I'm just really dumb I've said it as
many times two things consistent floor
gang me very dumb reckless is the right
word why am i wearing headphones I don't
need more views and I don't need more
fame why would I deliberately cause a
bunch of controversy so many people
start so strongly believing that there's
no such thing as bad publicity he
clearly did this on purpose
there's definitely something called bad
publicity a schlub and Paul this is the
best example you are tired of political
correctness we have this day and age you
would love doing more dark humor again
if it wouldn't immediately result in
shite reporting the comedy a lot
of times is walking that balance of
where it's okay to joke about and where
it's not and there can be a lot of
stress and tension around that and I
think that's why people like to laugh at
the dark humor because it alleviates
that
where the line goes I don't think really
matters it's not like darker is better I
think it's more of how you approach that
line it's something I've learned way too
late way too late dark over ng stuff to
me now it's just kind of cringing you
want to speak about some hot topics or
things that happen around the world but
you can't be honest because in that case
it will harm your reputation so it's the
same thing except I had talking about
topics I think it's fun to see both try
and at least understand both perspective
of different ideas and I like to play
devil's advocate so even if I don't
agree with something I like to try and
understand okay well how do they come to
this conclusion or is there something
good in their approach that's not
allowed to do online you cannot do that
people just immediately say oh you're
defending this or oh yeah it's it's not
a big deal but it's that's frustrating
to me more than the whole oh you've been
TPT or whatever people assume you're
racist well this is great because now I
can say flat out I'm not racist I don't
know the time and energy to raise this
and it if I had the time and energy
though was kidding
dice shouldn't joke got that me your
understand what I mean
I'm just saying like it doesn't even
make sense you are an extreme clean
freak you hate and feel unproductive
when your house is a mess that your
perfection is and all your videos have
to be perfect have you seen my camera
quality I'm not a perfectionist
whatsoever although it does look kind of
nicer and because I have the lights on
that's why you can see them clean free
yeah yeah I would say I think if you
take care of the things you have and
make sure they're clean you'll
appreciate them much more as opposed to
maybe you have a lot but it's really
messy and crazy I would much rather have
fewer things and really care for them
and I don't know if that has as much to
do with clean freak as how I look in
items you never give up you always
strive to be either next time that's
right if you never give up you can never
fail remember that gamers that was a all
right that was fun a lot nicer than I
thought it would be but thank you Thank
You members best a memory effect right
there
I feel like if I if I asked in the
general chat people would just make a
bunch of troll once yeah I feel like
that would be a good time to just say
thank you like I said before I think for
the first time in a long time I'm I'm
just genuinely happy with everything in
my life obviously there's things I wish
would change you know me and my sister
were supposed to move yada yada yada but
I think it's important to remember then
things will never be perfect and you
just need to be happy in the moment and
that's how I feel so and I feel very
grateful for my audience to have them so
thank you so much see you tomorrow in
another video epic brofist yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
exclusively at gmail.com